can sheeps eyes soup cure a hangover
we've created a facility to test the
world's greatest hangover cures and
we're gonna test them all I'm dr. Keller
wertham the doctor of internal medicine
I'm Frank Krantz I'm not a doctor but
I've been hungover a lot welcome to the
GPU hangover lab hmm yes so what's your
name my name is Daniel Nelson okay
started off the day with some beer I've
have a feeling we're gonna cover a lot
of alkali episode is this what you're
consuming at this point awesome for us
and for us bourbon on the list of
alcohols is up there near the top of
being really well its got the most
coders in it right conjugates exactly
and that is leave it at me congeners are
the other chemicals in alcohol that
aren't the part that get you drunk but
of the part that make you feel sick or
hungover or dehydrated oh wow I was told
to get drunk sounds like so you bring
out in ten thousand dollars okay usually
I had some expensive bourbon dirty bucks
tell me this is a strip club yeah it is
yeah right oh there you go he looks very
talented that okay so when you came in
we did a series of tests we checked your
vital signs your blood pressure your
poles your blood sugar it's a motor test
we also did a breathalyzer and you blew
a point oh four meaning you are still
guilty okay in the event that we cure
you everyone goes home happy so let's go
and let's introduce you to the cure
Daniel really let loose last night there
are some bold choices there and I think
people will know when you mix things
it's just a recipe for disaster I feel
like Daniels main complaint though was
the student with the stomping headache
the throbby the elephant pounding
headache it sounded like and what would
that that's dehydration is that there's
a little bit of a combo there one
there's dehydration it actually shrinks
your brain and pulls it away from the
attachments to your skull so you're your
brains not happy with that awful and the
other thing is these toxic chemicals
that build up that actually spasms the
brain so today's cure is Mongolian sheep
sighs soup this is a tradition that goes
back 100 even thousand years back
Genghis Khan this supposedly works this
is not just us make
in making [ __ ] up I mean this is a this
is a tried and true hangover cure the
treatment of choice for Mongolian hordes
okay please have a seat at the head of
the table now before I introduce the
cure I want to promise you we're not
just messing with you this is an old
tried-and-true Mongolian cure for a
hangover and if you didn't think the
Mongolians were already pretty hardcore
you will now sheeps eyes soup yeah
that's messed up that is so disgusting
is that the back of the eye that's that
that's like so the connective tissues
are actually probably the tens of the
intra ocular muscles that are impossible
for being able to move it around inter
ocular should never be in the same
sentence as a meal oh there's a lot of
eyes in there haha there's more I thank
you Oh what
does he need some motivation go go go go
go it's kind of gross there's water
let's go don't look at the glass too
close like Oh crickey back lie down but
yeah yeah yeah aah someone get rid of
that ha Oh relax Daniel you've earned it
am I gonna make it duck your blood
pressure definitely dropped for would
you feel pretty woozy like really like
really woozy yeah yeah your post is
still high i mean it's trying to
compensate for low blood pressure so
you're 2 point 0 1 i'm so winning i
think we should try to see how you are
with the up Lori Souter skills now we're
back to the the jumping tower we did 16
blocks in two minutes let's see if we
can beat it
oh okay should we got also they'll have
a seat again and talk about what just
happened yeah why not the good news
Daniel is that it's all over uh-huh but
up we want to know how do you feel I
probably feel worse now than I did
before you're feeling worse partly
because you're coming down off your
drunken state and we can't do anything
to avoid that besides give you more
alcohol which which is a hangover cure
in some people's boats but not the one
we're testing yeah sorry talk about
short straw but but the tomato-based
soup it has lycopene it's got 80
accidents those are good it's got salt
to replace your electrolytes uh-huh I
think we could have spared you and just
not with the eyeballs in their boat
we're Lions in science my friend Daniel
thanks a lot for coming to hang over
thanks Daniel for a gun again yeah you
know I think it's safe to say that we
just debunked the hangover cure yeah
yeah but there is something to be said
for just distraction I do think there is
some element there distraction that's
why I'm gonna give it a d okay uh-huh
all right I'm gonna have to grade this
hangover cure with F the tomato base
broth you know did have the potential to
kind of you know code is stomach give
him some sugar give him some salt right
well it's not like we were testing
tomato soup i'm fran kranz I'm dr.
Keller thanks for visiting the GQ
hangover lap
if you want to know more about what
hangover cures not to try subscribe to
the channel